Chris listeners know and you know that
there is a piece of legislation that's
been in place for many decades called
the Federal Fair Credit Reporting Act
which is how consumers interact with the
credit bureau mm-hmm there's also the
Federal Fair Debt collections Practices
Act that dictates the things that
collectors can and cannot do that's
right and they violate that pretty much
wholesale not all of them there are some
collectors that run a clean shop but the
credit card collection industry is an
example pretty much universally skum
pretty much violate that and of course
one things that happens when a collector
doesn't collect as they sue you get a
judgment lien against you and then they
take the money out of your bank account
this article saying the IRS began
sending out payments this week for the
Americas for the care stimulus Act
starting with those who already had bank
account information on file so the IRS
could do direct deposit for others the
IRS will send out paper checks though
that will take weeks or even months for
people to receive those a collection
agency can't garnish the cheque unless
you deposit it into an account it has
access to to avoid having the stimulus
payment garnished by a debt collector
monitor your bank account closely and
take out the money as quickly as
possible if they have a lien against
your account
so what's ending up happening is is the
collections industry has been stimulated
oh absolutely they have and they're
gonna continue to reach in and to grab
whatever they can that's alarming Dave
yeah and you know this happened for a
long time when we first started seeing
it when Social Security recipients
instead of getting a hard check in the
mail which they used to kind of be
beautiful checks actually they're very
ornate and Treasury check you know and
now some people still get a hard check
like that then make a physical deposit
but most people do direct deposit now
you cannot garnish it's illegal garnish
even Garcia wages but you can't garnish
a Social Security check right but you
can take the money out of someone's
account if it gets deposited and guess
what most Social Security checks are now
direct deposited so it's not unusual for
collectors to scarf Social Security
money when it comes in and the same
things true with the stimulus money if
they have a judgment lien against you
and a lien on your bank accounts and the
IRS sends this money into your account
you're getting no stimulus whatsoever
and the stimulation will occur at the
collection agents so you really have to
be on your guard on in these situations
and the sad thing is that a lot of
people that would be affected by this
are the very ones that no one tells this
stuff that's right that's exactly right
and Dave unfortunately I read also in
another article if you were using a tax
preparer that a lot of times that
stimulus check could be going toward
them if they've set up a bank account
for you because they removed their fee
and give you your refund right and so
it's really important as you said all
the way around everybody is to really be
plugged in on this and know exactly
what's going on with your account and be
like one of those ripoff advanced your
refund yes so like an H&R block advances
your refund but then they set up a
checking account in your name for the
refund to come back directly to them to
pay the loan they made you that's right
and if they if the IRS has that on file
they're gonna get your stimulus that's
where your students money's going to the
difference is I don't think H&R Block
will keep it no no I just have to go
find it a little higher filing because
you'll be wondering what do you why you
didn't get your check and there it is
over there because you did a stupid
refund advance loan that was stupid that
I mentioned that was stupid yeah I think
I mentioned that you said it do it one
more time stoop there we go hi let's
make sure it's a rimshot baby and a man
old man
and so yeah I didn't read that one you
know but I can I can visualize how that
happens so anyway the IRS has a bank
account number on you and you have done
business with them for any reason
through that bank account that may be
where your stimulus check is and if a
collector had a lien against it or if
you're still owed H&R Block little money
they would of course deduct that from
that now they're not taking this out
like a tax refund
they'll scarf that if you're behind on
your student loans oh yes but they're
not doing that with a stimulus check
they are sending these out in spite of
your student loan being in the vault as
I understand it and we did finally get a
ruling that it is not taxable for sure
that is correct David looking at this
they are calling this a tax credit it
will not be counted as income it's what
they're saying what tax experts are
saying right now and so again we got a
we got to wait and see I do love that
they have made everybody happy about
this they're giving you some of your
money and they're borrowing the money to
do that and everybody's just happy but
how were they borrowing they're all just
happy how are they born well they're in
debt the government's in debt it doesn't
do anything but borrow money it's got a
deficit it can't run up an extra two
million two trillion dollars in expense
without borrowing so they borrowed more
money of your money to give you your
money and now you feel like they gave
you a gift this is the greatest
emotional scam in history this thing
called government right just absolutely
where your butt out and you just oh
thank you thank you president Trump
thank you Nancy Pelosi for saving my
poor little life because you gave me
some of my money that you borrowed on my
behalf I mean what's the difference in
this well there's a difference because
you don't you'll never pay it be your
grandkids paying it but you run down run
up a credit card it's about the same
stinking thing except then you hand the
credit card to your grandkids that's
right well do you remember oK you've
been doing this 25 30 years what was the
debt the the smallest debt you can
remember us being in as a country how I
don't go back and look in 1992 I turned
on the microphone what the deficit was I
don't know okay cuz we're at 22 trillion
right now I would guess it was one or
two trillion fella hey my gas I mean
that's scary I don't look we ought to
look it up at the balcony I mean you
know but that's just scary that we just
added two trillion that quickly and
they're getting right to it again do you
think
do it again yeah they're they're not
through it's just it's just printing
money I mean how could it be of any harm
Wow
and let me just say I'm glad you guys
are getting some relief I'm not making
fun of you if you're hurting we're here
to help hurting people it's what we do
we're not throwing you under the bus but
darling if $1,200 changes your life your
financial life you were already
struggling hmm I mean you know you
already had trouble if $1,200 of you had
an income problem you had a debt problem
you had an outgo problem if $1,200 makes
you feel all warm and fuzzy then you are
already struggling long before you ever
heard the words coronavirus